لقد قمنا بالخطوة الأولى في FIFA من خلال
زيادة أموال الجائزة بشكل كبير
وهدفنا هو الوصول إلى
وضع المساواة في الأجر أه أه في كأس العالم المقبل
لكن البث وخاصة
المذيعين العامين الممول من أموال دافعي الضرائب
يجب أن يضعوا أفعالهم وراء
أقوالهم لأنهم ينتقدون بحق
أه منظمات كرة القدم أو
المنظمات الرياضية الأخرى لعدم دفعها بشكل
متساوٍ للنساء
والرجال ليس لديهم نفس السعر
المال جيدًا نحن بحاجة لتوليد هذه
الإيرادات ويجب عليهم مساعدتنا لأننا
بخلاف ذلك لن
نبيع هذه الحقوق
لهم بهذه الأسعار المقيمة بأقل من قيمتها الحقيقية.  حسنًا ،
لن يكون الجمهور الأوروبي قادرًا على مشاهدة
كأس العالم للسيدات ، والذي سيكون أمرًا مؤسفًا حقًا بعد
نجاح البطولة الأخيرة في فرنسا
بعد نجاح اليورو.